so we have f of X is equal to negative x
plus 4 and it's f of X is graphed right
here on our coordinate plane let's try
to figure out what the inverse of f is
and to figure out the inverse what I
like to do is I set Y I set the variable
y equal to f of X or we could write that
Y is equal to negative x plus 4 right
now we've solved for Y in terms of X to
solve for the inverse we do the opposite
we solve for X in terms of Y so let's
subtract 4 from both sides you get Y
minus 4 is equal to negative x and then
to solve for x we could multiply both
sides of this equation times negative 1
and so you get negative y plus 4 is
equal to X or just says we're always
used to writing the dependent variable
on the left hand side we could rewrite
this as x is equal to negative y plus 4
or another way to write it is we could
say that F inverse F inverse of Y is
equal to negative y plus 4 so we this is
the inverse function right here and
we've written it as a function of Y but
we can just rename the Y as X so it's a
function of X so let's do that
so if we just rename this y is X we get
F inverse of X is equal to negative x
plus 4 these two functions are identical
here we just use Y is the independent
variable or is the input variable here
we just use X for they're identical
functions now just out of interest let's
graph the inverse function and see how
it might relate to this one right over
here so if you look at it it actually
looks fairly identical it's negative x
plus 4 it's the exact same function so
let's see if we have the y intercept is
4 it's going to be the exact same thing
the function is its own inverse is its
own inverse so if we were to graph it we
would put it right on top of this right
on top of this and so there's a couple
of ways to think about it in the first
inverse function video I talked about
how a function and their inverse they
are the reflection over the line y
equals x so where is the line y equals x
here
well aligned y equals x looks like this
line y equals x looks like this and
negative X plus 4 is actually
perpendicular to Y is equal to X so when
you reflect it you're just kind of
flipping it over but it's going to be
the same line it is its own reflection
and let's make sure that that actually
makes sense when we're dealing with when
we're dealing with I guess this is the
standard function right there if you
input a 2 it gets mapped to a 2 if you
input a 4 it gets mapped to 0 what
happens if you go the other way if you
input a 2 well 2 to get some app 2 to
either way so that makes sense for the
regular function 4 gets mapped to 0 for
the inverse function 0 gets mapped to 4
so it actually makes complete sense
let's think about it another way for the
regular function let me write it
explicitly down this might be obvious to
you but just in case it's not it might
be helpful for so f of let's pick F of 5
f of 5 is equal to negative 1
or we could say the function f Maps us
from 5 to negative 1 now what does what
does F inverse do what's F inverse F
inverse of negative 1 F inverse of
negative 1 is 5 is equal to 5 or we
could say that F Maps us from negative 1
to 5 so once again if you think about
kind of the sets there are domains and
our ranges so let's say that this is the
domain of F this is the range of F F
will take us from F will take us from 5
5 to negative 1 that's what the function
f does and we see that F inverse takes
us back from negative 1 to 5 F inverse
takes us back from negative 1 to 5 just
like just like it's supposed to do let's
do one more of these so here I have G of
X is equal to negative 2x minus 1 so
just like the last problem I like to
just set y equal to this so we say Y is
equal to G of X which is equal to
negative 2x minus 1 now we just solve
for X y plus 1 is equal to negative 2x
just added 1 to both sides now we can
divide both sides of this equation by
negative 2 and so you get negative Y
over 2 minus 1/2 is equal to X or we
could write X is equal to negative Y
over 2 minus 1/2 or we could write F
inverse as a function of Y is equal to
negative Y over 2 minus 1/2 or we could
just rename Y as X and we could say that
F inverse F inverse of oh maybe careful
here that shouldn't be an F the original
function was G so let me be clear that
is G inverse of Y G inverse of Y is
equal to negative Y over 2 minus 1/2
this we started with the G of X on an f
of X make sure we get our notation right
or we could just rename the Y and say G
inverse of X is equal to negative x over
2 minus 1/2 now let's graph it it's
y-intercept is negative 1/2 so it's
right over there and it has a slope of
negative 1/2 it has a slope of negative
1/2 let's see if we start at negative
1/2 if we move over to 1 in the positive
direction we'll go down 1/2 if we move
over 1 again we'll go down 1/2 again if
we move back with so we'll go like that
so the line I'll try my best I'll try my
best to draw it will look something like
that it will just keep going so it'll
look something like that I'll keep going
in both directions and now let's see if
this really is a reflection over y
equals X y equal X y equals x looks like
looks like that and you can see they are
reflections if you reflect this guy if
you reflect this blue line it becomes
this orange line but the general idea
you literally just the function is
originally expressed is solved for Y in
terms of X you just do some algebra
solve for X in terms of Y and that's
essentially your inverse function as a
function of Y but then you
can rename it as a function of X